Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Ich habe ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht, wie wir diese ganzen netzpolitischen Probleme vom Hals kriegen. Wir schließen einfach das Internet.
Reden wir kurz mit Bill Gates und dann ist heute Nachmittagsschicht.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik, hundertdreiundsechzig, viele Ausgaben wird's nicht mehr geben, weil wenn das Internet dann erstmal abgeschaltet ist, dann äh weiß ich auch nicht, dann können wir uns mal wieder auf Urban Gardening zurückziehen oder sowas.
Kann sich nur noch um Stunden handeln.
Aber soll du als Trollexperte irgendwie, was sagst du zu diesem zu diesem weiß ich nicht, dieser dieser Roboter gesteuerten Perücke da.
Da fällt einem doch heute hier auch nicht mehr viel zu ein, oder?
Äh hart. Ist gut.
Hat so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass Tollerei jetzt irgendwie auch auf so einem politischen Level und gesellschaftlichen Level angekommen ist und das, dass da, dass auch dieser öffentliche Diskurs davon genauso ähm,
wenn ich zäher stört, wird doch zumindest angegriffen ist, äh wie wir das so im Kleinen in unseren sozialen Medien auch schon gesehen haben, dass das einfach,
Dinge aus der Spur bringt und ähm eine eine richtige Debatte gar nicht mehr so äh ermöglicht.
Ja, bei dem Trump, ich weiß, also ich meine, ich glaube nicht, dass das ein Troll ist. Ja, also in seiner, ich meine.
Deine Strategie ist rollig. Das meine ich.
Seine Strategie ist drollig, aber halt auch schweinegefährlich, ne. Also ich meine, das nicht jeder, der der Stuss redet, ist sie treu. Ich meine, das Problem bei Donald Trump ist, dass der ja offenbar tatsächlich irgendwie äh Chancen hat,
Das ist eigentlich, ich meine, weißt du, wenn das jetzt Martin Sonneborn wär, dann würde ich sagen, super.
Ist es halt nicht.
Wieder. Ja gut, aber ich meine, trotzdem scheint ja so, sagen wir mal so eine aufgeklärte äh Öffentlichkeit, so sieht denn überhaupt noch existiert. Äh ihre Schwierigkeiten haben zu haben, das eingeheckt zu bekommen.
Das ist sozusagen das, was ich äh beobachte.
Ja, das das mag sein, aber wir haben auch in Deutschland gerade äh Schwierigkeiten, bestimmte politische Beiträge von komischen Menschen äh irgendwie einzu.
Ich
das auch gar nicht auf die USA beschränken. Also ich sehe das schon auch so ein bisschen als globales äh Phänomen und das mag jetzt nicht unbedingt eine Folge des Internets sein, aber es ist halt einfach, sagen wir mal, zumindest eine Konsequenz unserer äh globalisierten Medienöffentlichkeit.
Also du sagst es, die Welt ist zur Treugrube geworden und wir müssen jetzt alle Freds irgendwann mal dicht machen.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass ich irgendwelche Antworten parat habe. Ich sehe nur Probleme.
Politik ist die Fortführung des Flame Wars mit anderen Mitteln.
Ja, am Ende, ja, ich hoffe, das wird da ausreichend gestellt sind durch unsere Vorvergangenheit.
Ich hoffe mal, dass da irgendwie die Vorvergangenheit, also ich hoffe mal, dass wir das mit einer äh ich sage mal eine,
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob eine eine gepflegte Sozialisation irgendwie ausreicht für das, was kommt, wenn Donald Trump Präsident würde.
Die Befürchtung habe ich auch. Gut.
Wir uns eine gewissen Restoptimismus. Äh den brauchen wir auch, wenn ich mir allein schon die Themenliste der heutigen Sendung anschaue. Wollen wir erstmal mit Feedback anfangen?
Ja, wir haben ja äh in der letzten Sendung kurz erwähnt, dass es äh Smart Homes gibt,
und ähm kurz erwähnt, dass viele der Implementierungen eben nicht wirklich ein smartes Home sind, sondern,
dummes Home, was irgendwie versteuert ist oder so und da haben wir eine
E-Mail bekommen von Uwe Fräse, der mich darauf hinweist, dass es ein nettes Projekt äh mit von Grund auf eigenem Protokoll, Verschlüsselung und so weiter gibt, dass äh unter Smarthomatic Punkt ORG,
zu aufzufinden ist und,
dass er uns und den Hörenden ans äh ans Herz legen möchte, nicht nur das zu nutzen, sondern auch die Entwicklung voranzubringen.
Ja, das jetzt mal gedropt.
Ungeprüft.
Ungeprüft einfach so. Wir geben dem jetzt einfach mal äh die Chance des Zweifels.
Das ist, also ich meine, ist grundsätzlich wichtig, solche Sachen. Natürlich äh Quell offen und Community entwickelt zu halten und ähm,
Das ist ein Grundstein dessen, dass man sich überhaupt über den ganzen Mist noch beschweren kann. Ja, wir brauchen ja auch so ein so ein Alibilinox, um,
Das wird nicht mehr lange dauern. Nein, aber natürlich ist es wichtig, solche Projekte auch zu haben,
ähm und weiterzuentwickeln.
Genau. Das wird ja auch getan, auch auf dem Kongress. Wirst wahrscheinlich auch auf den Kongress, oder?
Ja, ich wollte da mal vorbeigehen.
Nee, ich meine, nicht du, sondern er.
Hat er nicht geschrieben.
Naja, wir werden's sehen. Tickets sind ja nun leider knapp.
Also wenn das mal ich sage mal, wenn das Smarthome funktioniert, kann das ja kann er ja rüberkommen.
Ah, okay.
So, womit geht's denn äh los? Also wir gehen mal nach äh Europa. Da brechen auch schon wieder die Pfeiler äh ein, die mühsam eingeschlagen worden sind.
Ja, der Innenausschuss des EU Parlaments hat jetzt für eine geplante Richtlinie zur Fluggastdaten Vorratsdatenspeicherung gestimmt.
Das sogenannte Peser nehmen, Record Konzept, also PNR, hatten wir hier auch schon mehrfach angesprochen und eigentlich auch berichtet, dass es da ganz gute Ergebnisse gab, unter anderem hat das EU-Parlament auch schon mal eine andere Position eingenommen.
Genau, es war nämlich eigentlich so, dass äh dass es eine äh recht einschränkende Position des Parlamentes gab,
Aber dann eben der gute Berichterstatter äh Timothy
Kirk Hope äh mit den Mitgliedsstaaten und der EU-Kommission einen anderen Deal ausgehandelt hat und für diesen Deal haben jetzt achtunddreißig Abgeordnete aus diesem Ausschuss äh gestimmt. Neunzehn dagegen, zwei haben sich enthalten,
Es geht dabei darum, sechzig Datenkategorien äh festzuhalten für fünf Jahre. Zu den Daten gehören neben Name, E-Mail,
Telefon, Konten, Kreditkartennummern, außer Dinge wie Essenswünsche, also einmal alles, was so 'ne Airline über dem Passagier oder die Passagiere erfasst.
Sehr, sehr wichtig zu wissen, was du gegessen hast, um rauszufinden, ob du einen Terrorist bist. Ja.
Genau. Das hilft bei der Aufklärung, denn auf diese Datensammlung dürfen Sicherheitsbehörden bei Terrorismus und anderen schweren Straftaten zugreifen. Ähm.
Wie gesagt, es ist sehr viel mehr als ähm die Innenpolitiker des EU-Parlaments im im Juli erst
erstmals befürwortet hatten, wo sie gesagt haben, okay, geh bitte mit folgender Position in diese Verhandlungen
Und was aber jetzt passieren wird, ist, diese Daten sollen sechs Monate unmaskiert und dann eben die restlichen viereinhalb Jahre ohne direkten Personenbezug aufbewahrt werden,
Aber diese viereinhalb für viereinhalb Jahre gespeicherten maskierten Daten
unter Umständen redentifiziert werden. Das ist eigentlich ganz geil. Also du sagst irgendwie so, ja, ja, die Daten werden ja anonymisiert, gespeichert, nur diese Anonymisierung können wir rückgängig machen. Das ist auch immer so ein Hütchenspielertrick.
Wieso? Ist doch alles anonymisiert. Es ist genauso wie wie dir so ein E-Mail-Anbieter sagt, ist alles verschlüsselt. Ist alles voll, wir haben wir haben den Schlüssel, klar, aber ist alles verschlüsselt. Kannst du alter Hütchenspielertrick funktioniert jedes Mal wieder,
Und ähm nehmen den Transkontinentalflügen ja, das galt zunächst,
In der Vereinbarung vom Juli, von der in der Parlamentsposition vom Juli erstmal nur für Transkontinentale Flüge, aber jetzt sollen freiwillig auch innereuropäische Strecken erfasst werden.
Und der EU-Rat hat sich schon am Freitag darauf verständigt, dass alle Mitgliedsstaaten da freiwillig mitmachen.
Ja, das heißt, dann haben wir also nicht nur transkontinentalflüge, sondern auch innerhalb äh EU innerhalb der EU alle Flüge äh fünfeinhalb Jahre alle Flugbewegungen aufgesammelt und im Zugriff,
Also wir wissen ja, dass wir in den letzten Jahren sehr, sehr viele Probleme damit hatten, dass wir ähm,
Terrorismus nicht aufklären konnten, weil wir einfach nicht wussten, was die Leute im Flugzeug gegessen haben.
Und wer von Leipzig nach Frankfurt geflogen ist.
Genau. Na ja, was also es heißt halt klar, ich meine, im Zweifelsfall können sie dann jederzeit vollständig darauf zugreifen, was es für Flugbewegungen innerhalb und innerhalb,
oder was es für Flugbewegungen gab, bei denen mindestens eine Seite ein europäischer Flughafen war. Das heißt es letztendlich,
Es ist halt eine vollständige Erfassung der Reisebewegungen mit diesem Mittel,
Ist schon krasse Ansage. Ich meine, wenn du überlegst, dass wir
das hat jetzt keinen direkten Bezug zu schenken, aber irgendwie so diese Idee mit dem, dass man einfach mal ohne Grenzkontrollen sich hier bewegen kann innerhalb Europas und so äh finde ich es schon davon berührt, wenn all diese Bewegungsdaten eben für fünf Jahre gespeichert werden, ne.
Und es, wir haben ja das Urteil zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung von Kommunikationsdaten des EUGH und der hatte ja damals sich schon auch klar dagegen ausgesprochen, dass es irgendwelche anlasslosen Sammlungen äh personenbezogener Daten geben soll.
Und genau dieser EuGH prüft gerade das geplante Fluggastdatenabkommen zwischen der EU und Kanada,
Um zu schauen, ob das überhaupt mit den Grundrechten vereinbar ist und während das so passiert, weißt du, während denen die die
ähm Kommunikationsvorratsdatenspeicherung weggesicht wird und die das PNR-Abkommen mit Kanada geprüft wird, sagen sie, alles klar, machen wir direkt weiter hier. Ähm bloß nicht irgendwie aus der Übung kommen.
Und währenddessen sitzt da noch der EU-Ministerrat da und sagt, ja, jetzt müssen wir auch irgendwie nochmal über eine Neufassung,
der Richtlinie zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung diskutieren, weil es kann ja nicht sein, dass wir nicht alle EU-Mitglieder zur Speicherung von Telefon und Internetverbindungsdaten verpflichten.
Ja, also das ist äh ja,
Ich habe auch so langsam so den Eindruck, dass das auch auf europäischer Ebene mittelfristig äh sich einfach,
nur noch ein nennenswerter äh Widerstand formieren lässt, indem man einfach mit dem europäischen Gerichtshof äh gegen alles, was das EU-Parlament und äh die Kommission so beschließt, vorgeht.
So einen Zustand, wie wir ihn in Deutschland nun auch schon seit längerer Zeit haben.
Weiß nicht, ob das dann genauso erfolgreich sein wird, aber zumindest gibt's auch hier so eine starke Dissonanz zwischen äh dem, was so an ähm Festellungen der des EuGH äh vorliegt und dem, was letzten Endes äh angesetztes Paketen und Richtlinien beschlossen wird.
Ja, das ähm, ich meine, so eine Feststellung ist kein gutes Zeichen, ne? Also, wenn du sagst, okay, wir müssen unsere gesamte Freiheitspolitik auf die äh höchsten Gerichte konzentrieren, dann weißt du, wie der Wind steht, ne?
Ja und wenn man sich dann so Länder wie Polen anschaut, die jetzt nach dem Regierungswechsel erstmal nichts besseres zu tun haben, als ihr komplettes Verfassungsgericht auszutauschen und äh auf die Linie zu bringen, dann äh.
Ist das halt auch äh langfristig nicht unbedingt jetzt eine Absicherung, die einen ruhig schlafen lässt.
Haben wir ja auch diese Idee haben wir ja von den äh,
Zeh Promis, äh C-Prolis, C-Politikern, äh auch erst vor ein paar Monaten gehört, dass man sich gedacht hat, jetzt mit dem Karlsruher, hör mal, die behindern hier unsere Arbeit, da müssen wir mal was machen. Ja, also diese Forderung gab's ja auch schon.
Na ja, das wird sicherlich auch wiederkommen. Und in Ungarn sieht man ja auch schon, wie weit das äh gedeihen kann und was das für Konsequenzen hat. Nicht schön.
Also Rat, das Ratstreffen hielt fest, alle Mitgliedsstaaten waren der Auffassung, dass die massenhafte Sammlung elektronischer Kommunikationsdaten prinzipiell weiterhin erlaubt ist. Auch schön, ne?
Eine Mehrheit der Delegationen ist außerdem der Meinung, dass ein EU weiter Vorstoß geprüft werden müsse, um die Zersplitterung des Rechtsrahmens bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung innerhalb der EU zu beenden,
und lud die Kommission dazu ein, einen neuen Gesetzentwurf vorzulegen, wann immer es möglich ist.
Außerdem wurde beschlossen, dass die Erde eine Scheibe ist.
Ja, das soll ja das ja sowieso, ich meine. Also, naja, du, du siehst, es ist ja, du, das ist die äh Missachten vollständig, äh, dieses, dieses Organ, ja, oder die, die Äußerungen,
dieses Organes, ja? Wenn sagt, OK wir wir machen wir machen einfach ein Gesetz und wenn es das kassiert wird, dann gucken wir was wir ändern müssen und versuchen das da wieder vorbei zu schieben, ja? Und das das funktioniert auf diese Weise überall, ja?
Woanders würde man also bei anderen die so klar irgendwie die Verfassung nicht,
Würde man da wahrscheinlich herrschere Kritik finden, als bei äh der EU-Kommission oder dem EU-Rat, der sagt, ja wunderbar, äh schade, dass es jetzt beim ersten Mal nicht geklappt hat,
müssen wir mal gucken.
Ja wir machen das einfach so lange, bis es durchkommt.
So läuft's.
Aber in Deutschland ist doch alles super, oder?
Deutschland sind die Gerichte auf auf unserer Seite.
Auf Zack, da kann nichts schief gehen, da brennt nichts an.
Ja, wir haben den Feier schon behandelt vom Springer Verlag, der gegen diese äh Werbeblocker,
Los geht an vielen verschiedenen, auf vielen verschiedenen Ebenen. Ähm einmal direkt gegen IO,
die irgendwie einen nur einen Forum-Post auf ihrer Seite hatten. Wir haben diesen Fall des äh YouTubers Tobias, hieß er, glaube ich, der äh da abgemahnt wurde
und der sich ja jetzt auch ähm im Rahmen einer negativen Feststellungsklage dagegen zur Wehr setzt und wir beobachten.
Gleichzeitig drei Urteile aus äh vom drei Landgerichtsurteile Hamburg, Frankfurt, Stuttgart, in Hamburg wurde eine einstweilige Verfügung gegen IO bestätigt, da ging's also um diesen
Vor und Post die Begründung des Urteils liegt noch nicht vor, aber es ist vermutlich so, dass sie sich auf diese Argumentation
auf Basis von Paragraph fünfundachtzig A des Uhr war, Rechtsgesetzes,
gelassen haben. Das war also die Argumentation von Springer, dass sie gesagt haben, na ja, dieser Werbeblockerblocker ist eine,
Wirksame Methode zur Durchsetzung,
der ähm der Ziele des Urhebers, wie sein Werk zu nutzen sei und wie nicht. Ja?
Und wir hatten ja damals schon in unserer Laien, mit unserer Laienkenntnis, äh, festgestellt, dass diese vom reinen Gesetzestext hätte es wahrscheinlich auch hinkommt, ja, die hatten damals was ganz anderes im Kopf, als dieser Absatz geschrieben wurde. Da ging's eben eigentlich um die Manifestation von.
Äh von DVD, Kopierschützen,
die nicht funktionierten und äh man sieht da jetzt, dass äh nahe gibt's jetzt einen schönen äh Kollateralschaden, so auch am Landgericht Frankfurt, wo die beiden ähm,
äh Angebote und AdBlock von Beta-Fisch im Eilverfahren ohne mündliche Verhandlungen
durch zwei einstweilige Verfügung gegen die Programme gesperrt wurden. Dieses Edschild ist jetzt auch im im App Store nicht mehr verfügbar,
Und am Landgericht Stuttgart hatte die Verlag also die Tochter von Springer, nämlich N vierundzwanzig GmbH. Äh versucht die iOS App Blocker zu verbieten,
Auf Basis des Gesetzes gegen den unlauteren Wettbewerb. Ähm,
Wettbewerb ist immer dann, wenn du quasi.
Gegen einen Wettbewerber und lauter Fourgehs. Gut erklärt, ne, aber äh da gibt's quasi, da gibt's bestimmte, bestimmte Vorgaben, wann du die Grenzen des,
des rechtlichen Überschreites in in dem Umgang mit einem äh dir im mit dir im Wettbewerb stehenden Marktteilnehmers. Und,
Das Landgericht Stuttgart wollte da allerdings nicht ohne eine mündliche Verhandlung entscheiden. Ähm,
und na, offenbar teilte das Gericht dann in der Verhandlung am neunzehnten November nicht die Auffassung der Springeranwälte, wonach
Blogger eine gezielte Behinderung eines Mitbewerbers darstelle. Also das heißt, die haben sich hauptsächlich darauf berufen, dass sie gesagt haben ähm.
Blogger,
Ist einfach kein Mitbewerber und deswegen ist das auch keine gezielte Blockade eurer äh Interessen, ja? Aber auch da, da habe ich jetzt nur spekuliert, denn ähm das Urteil soll bald verkündet werden, ja?
Also da geht's geht's kräftig weiter und währenddessen rüstet sich eben Tobias mit seinem Anwalt zur negativen Feststellungsklage und da kann man ihm nur ähm viel Erfolg bei wünschen.
Mhm. Aber hat jetzt noch nichts gesagt, wann das so weit ist.
Ähm da gibt es ein paar, also es wird vermutlich erst im nächsten Jahr dann soweit sein, ja, oder gibt's halt ein paar äh Überlegungen grade.
So, aber.
Gute Nachrichten? Ich weiß es nicht.
Das ist jetzt gute Nachrichten. Klingt jetzt erst mal nicht so falsch, oder?
Na ja, also das ist halt von Heiko Maas. Heiko Maas. Fängt aber gut an. So.
Ja. Na der fängt immer gut an. Na? Und dann kommen die anderen und sagen, hey Heiko, das hast du jetzt nicht wirklich gemacht, oder? Das. Ab in die Ecke.
So, das da kippst du jetzt um. Ja, Heiko Maas hat äh nachdem.
Martin Schulz, der Präsident des EU Parlaments. Vor ein paar Wochen eine Internetkater äh gefordert hat, hat Heiko Maas,
Einen äh Vorschlag entworfen und aufgeschrieben, einer Internetkater der digitalen Grundrechte. Und.
Dabei zahlt online veröffentlicht.
Website online veröffentlicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob die damit jetzt schon gültig ist.
Na ja.
Er hat also dreizehn Thesen angeschlagen oder dreizehn Artikel und der erste Artikel ist, jeder Mensch hat das Recht auf Zugang zum Internet.
Ja. Bist dabei? Äh interessant wäre dann halt mal zu sehen.
Ob davon auch so Ideen wie dieses Hadofi betroffen wären, was ja in Frankreich irgendwie nach wie vor äh als ernst erst gemeinte Maßnahme diskutiert wird, dass man das einem der Internetanschluss weggenommen wird.
Die sogenannte Regelung. So.
Man kann sich andererseits natürlich auch da anschauen, was ist mit den ähm,
Mit Geringverdienenden, ja, oder mit auf ländlichen Regionen wohnenden. Wir hatten ja auch darüber gesprochen, dass die Bundesregierung inzwischen ja meint, ja, das mit diesen, mit diesen fünfzehn fünfzig MBit flächendecken, müssen wir nochmal gucken.
Bin so und so vier Jahren. Mhm.
Also er, er sagt hier, nicht nur der Netzausbau ist nötig, auch der tatsächliche und faire Zugang für alle muss Realität werden. Schöne Worte, Heiko, wenig konkret. Das gilt hier für alles, ne. Ich meine, das sind wieder irgendwelche so Gummiparagrafen,
aber immerhin.
Ich will das jetzt gar nicht so runter machen. Ich meine, das ist jetzt erstmal aufgeschrieben und das ist äh in der Tendenz und in seiner Grundaussage weicht das jetzt von der HK-Ethik jetzt auch nicht so weit ab.
Hast du Heiko, hast einen Heiko Maas einen Nachhagen genannt?
In den nicht gegangen, aber.
Ähm.
Ich lese sagen wir mal eine ähnliche Forderung auch äh daraus äh heraus, ja.
Zugang zu Computern soll, uneingeschränkt sein et cetera. Da war das Internet jetzt sozusagen noch nicht äh explizit genannt, aber das ist, sagen wir mal, im selben Geiste und das äh also mit Artikel eins,
immer mit.
Artikel zwei wahrscheinlich genauso, denn Artikel zwei lautet, jeder Mensch hat das Recht über seine persönlichen Daten selbst zu bestimmen. Die Entsprechung zur Hacker-Ethik ist hier, lieber Tim.
Private Daten schützen.
Öffentliche Daten nutzen und bilde nicht in.
Genau, die zwei Zusatz äh die zwei Zusatzthesen von äh Wow, die der damaligen äh Hakaethik quasi noch in Deutschland hinzugefügt wurden.
Genau, da bezieht er sich auf die Daten als Öl des einundzwanzigsten Jahrhunderts und ähm insbesondere benennt er sich äh äh bezieht er sich hier auf die neue EU-Datenschutzgrundverordnung,
mit Hilfe derer. Wir alle diesem Ideal ein Stück näher kommen.
Ja, ja, die in diesen Tagen beschlossen wird. Ich meine, das,
der noch ausstehenden Verwässerung im Kontext grade solcher Beschlüsse wie dem eben schon angesprochenen PNR, wo ich halt äh schon mal an eine absolute Diskrepanz sehe zwischen dem, was da beschlossen wird und dem, was
theoretisch nach aktueller Diskussionsstand mit der EU-Datenschutzgrundverordnung äh erreicht werden soll,
Also das werden wir nochmal sehen, ob das sozusagen wirklich dazu führt, dass wir diesem Ideal näher kommen, aber schön wär's. Äh ja, die,
Hoheit über die eigenen Datenraum. Sind wir auch dabei.
Artikel drei. Jeder Mensch hat das Recht über seine digitale Identität selbst zu bestimmen. Jeder Mensch hat ein Recht auf Vergessenwerden. Da wird schon interessant, ja? Also seine digitale Identität, wieso bitteschön nur eine,
Ja, finde ich schon mal witzig, ja. Ähm.
Ja. Guter Punkt und das vergessen werden ist natürlich jetzt wirklich sehr knifflig.
Ja, mit dem Vergessen werden wissen wir, da gibt's im Prinzip diese äh die einzige Implementierung des Rechts auf vergessen werden, ist das, was irgendwie als äh äh auf dieser auf diese
Google Geschichte sich bezog, ne, wo man letztendlich gesagt hat, okay, wenn über dich in in den Medien etwas schlechtes stand,
Ähm dann
hast du keine Handhabe dem Medium gegenüber es zur Löschung zu veranlassen, aber du hast gegenüber Google eine Handhabe, das aus den Suchergebnissen
löschen zu lassen, weil Google ja ein Profil über dich abbildet und dieses Profil kannst du ja beeinflussen. Und ähm,
Er sagt dir sogar,
Er sagte sogar explizit, damit etwa Jugendsünden nichts für lebenslangen Belastungen werden dürfen, Suchmaschinen, dann bestimmte personenbezogene Einträge nicht mehr anzeigen. Das ist ja auch genau das, was wir mit diesem Recht auch vergessen werden, Urteil
Google sehen, dass die ganzen äh Wirtschaftskriminellen jetzt irgendwie ihre ersten zehn Google-Treffer bereinigen lassen. So, das ist eigentlich das, was da stattfindet, ne?
Genau. Mit Judensünden hat das erstmal wenig zu tun. Wobei ich jetzt auch nicht sagen würde, dass diese Idee des Vergessens im Netz,
nicht auch diskussionswert ist, nicht unbedingt jetzt in der Form, wie wir das bisher
umgesetzt gesehen haben, aber sagen wir mal, ähm
bewege mich auf Plattform X und ich könnte äh einstellen, dass ähm und hätte auch sozusagen ein Anrecht auf eine solche Funktion, dass sich bestimmte Informationen mit einem Verfallsdatum preisgebe.
Ohne ohne Frage, das ist quasi diese Idee des digitalen Radiergummis. Ähm,
für die es bisher eigentlich keine keine funktionierende technische Entsprechung gibt, aber ähm es ist hier, also es ist ein,
durchaus, sage ich mal, ein eine Herausforderung für unsere Gesellschaft und es muss irgendwie dieses Recht auf vergessen werden, geben, aber man sieht halt auch, sobald das eingeräumt wird, dass es dass es von.
Dass es zur Anwendung dieses Rechtes kommt, die nicht unbedingt im Interesse der Allgemeinheit sind,
Also schwieriger Fall, den werden wir jetzt hier nicht lösen können. Ähm grundsätzlich ist das natürlich schon klar, dass man irgendwie sich wünschen sollte, ähm dass Menschen da irgendwie einen einen Schutz genießen und auch Nachsicht,
äh gilt,
Aber wie gesagt, die bisherigen äh Realwelt-Implementierungen sind äh zweifelhaft.
Artikel vier. Kein Mensch darf zum Objekt eines Algorithmus werden.
Tja.
Da weiß ich nicht genau, was der ähm,
Okay, das muss man vorlesen. Das lässt man einfach so viel. Ich lese das jetzt vor und dann steht das für sich. In Zeiten von Big Data werden aus Analysen vergangenen Verhaltensprognosen für die Zukunft erstellt.
Aber der Mensch ist mehr als sein Datenprofil und menschliches Verhalten lässt sich nicht wertneutral berechnen. Jeder Algorithmus basiert auf Annahmen, die falsch oder diskriminierend sein können,
soweit, so gut. Schlussfolgerungen,
Wir brauchen deshalb einen Algorithmen-TÜV, der die Lauterkeit der Programmierung gewährleistet und auch sicherstellt, dass unsere Handlungs- und Entscheidungsfreiheit nicht manipuliert wird. Maschinen haben keine eigene Ethik und empfinden keine Empathie
Nachteilige Entscheidungen dürfen daher nicht allein von Algorithmen getroffen werden,
dürfen nicht blind auf Statistiken und Big Data vertrauen, denn eine richtige Entscheidung muss nicht nur effizient, sondern auch gerecht sein.
Das ist sehr spannend, da wird die Schufa sich freuen.
Dachte mir auch, dass die als erstes anrufen, war Heiko, das hast du nicht geschrieben, oder? Ja, also ähm,
schöne Worte. Äh ich frage mich, was die Konsequenz daraus ist oder was hier so dahinter äh Gedanke ist. Ich habe halt immer so ein bisschen dieses pauschale Google-Bashing, was derzeit einfach immer noch so äh en vogue ist,
In unserem äh Politiksegment im im Hinterkopf, ohne dass jetzt hier,
weiß nicht, ob der über Schufa überhaupt nachgedacht hat in diesem Moment.
Nachgedacht, meinst du? Ja. Weiß ich nicht, ob der nachgedacht hat.
Ich meine, wenn man dem jetzt folgt, müsste man sozusagen diverse äh auch Gerichtsurteile, die es zuletzt gab in Punkto Schufa, im Prinzip wieder revidieren, ne.
Also was äh was äh,
Ich meine, allein dieser Satz, kein Mensch darf zum Objekt eines Algorithmus werden, da muss er sich halt mit Donald Trump und Bill Gates irgendwie zusammensetzen und dem Ganzen ein Ende machen. Natürlich sind ähm alle Menschen.
Beziehungsweise ihre Daten, Objekt eines Algorithmus,
Wenn sie irgendwo bei Facebook bei Twitter egal, so kommt sofort irgendein Algorithmus vorbei, nimmt deine Daten und macht damit was. Ja, dafür haben wir Computer programmiert. Was er natürlich eigentlich meint, ist.
Soll keine Bewertung.
Steht über dem Algorithmus. Der Mensch muss am Ende über dem Algorithmus stehen. Es darf nicht äh eine reine Bestimmung durch Algorithmen geben. Denn Maschinen haben keine eigene Ethik und empfinden keine Empathie. Ähm,
Und der entscheidende Satz ist hier, nachteilige Entscheidungen dürfen daher nicht allein von Algorithmen getroffen werden, ja? Das ist also, glaube ich, sehr schwammig
und äh eventuell werden dann, wenn irgendwie die Maschinen übernommen haben und uns alle unter Jochen äh werden sie eventuell halt,
an diesem Artikel scheitern, ja. So, aber viel früher kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass der ernsthaft mal zum Tragen käme, ihr.
Gar kein Problem. Skynet nimmt sie einfach noch ein paar Menschen mit den Sekretariat, die dann sozusagen am Schluss nochmal ihren Friedrich-Wilhelm runtersitzen und dann läuft das auch.
Du, ich finde das, stell dir mal vor, Skynet kommt und denkt man so, fuck!
Ah
Ansonsten so kurz vor dem Ziel und jetzt das. Hm.
Artikel fünf,
Jeder Mensch hat das Recht, seine Meinung im Internet frei zu äußern und zu verbreiten und sich aus allgemein zugänglichen Quellen ungehindert zu unterrichten. Eine Zensur,
findet nicht statt. Ja, das ist etwas umformuliert natürlich Artikel fünf des Grundgesetzes. Und da sagt er, ja ähm.
Oh meine Güte, da hat er irgendwie noch so ein irgendwie. Oder so, da da wird der aber echt spannend. Das finde ich ja witzig. Dann nennt er als Beispiel,
Das digitale Gegenöffentlichkeit auch bei uns wichtig ist, hat gerade das Olympiareferendum von Hamburg gezeigt
alle Parteien und klassischen Medien waren Pro Olympia, aber die Mehrheitswillen der Menschen hat hinein Kampagne repräsentiert, die sich im Internet organisiert hat, jetzt ist das Internet irgendwie die Wahrheit. Darauf sollte man ihn irgendwann nochmal festnageln.
Finde ich aber bemerkenswert. Ja.
Ja, es ist bemerkenswert.
Also ich, ja, politischer Diskurs hin äh und her, ich finde er fügt der Debatte auf jeden Fall deutlich interessantere Aspekte hinzu, als wir das, sagen wir mal, aus dem CSU-Lager kennen.
Das auf jeden Fall, aber natürlich,
Kann, ne, diese Meinungsfreiheit nicht äh nicht uneingeschränkt bleiben, deswegen gibt es Artikel sechs. Das Recht, seine Meinung im Internet zu äußern, befreit niemanden davon
Die allgemeinen Gesetze und das Persönlichkeitsrecht seiner Mitmenschen zu beachten. Ja und mit die allgemeinen Gesetze,
Hast du quasi die.
Gut, ich meine, das ist wie im richtigen Leben auch so. Äh ist halt die These mit die Freiheit des Einzelnen inne, da wo die des Anderen beginnt und ähm ja, das war jetzt zu erwarten, dass das hier auch noch daher kommt. Finde ich jetzt auch erstmal nicht falsch.
Wir kennen ja auch ähm Heiko Maaßens Engagement äh Facebook
äh zu einer äh effizienteren Löschung von äh Hassaufrufen äh zu bewegen, das äh wiederholt er hier auch, auch im Netz, darf man Hass, Hetze und Beleidigungen nicht ungestraft über seine Mitmenschen ausschütten,
das ist auch klar. Der ähm rechtliche Rahmen hier für äh ist entsprechend zu setzen,
und hat natürlich seine äh Schwierigkeiten oder was heißt seine Schwierigkeit.
Also Justizministerium bewirft Facebook jetzt immerhin schon seit Monaten mit Watteborsch hier, um das äh auch zu ändern. Muss man.
Er sagt zum Beispiel, es ist gut, dass die Justiz jetzt konsequenter eingreift, wenn etwa im Netz dazu aufgerufen wird, äh Unterkünfte für Geflüchtete in Brand zu setzen,
und er näht auch direkt dieses Beispiel äh ebenso tut Facebook gut daran, endlich seine Verantwortung wahrzunehmen. Ähm.
Das wäre auch schon, wenn die Justiz konsequenter eingreift, äh wenn ich nur dazu aufgerufen wird, sondern wird es auch getan wird.
Da könnte David die Justiz sicherlich dann irgendwann eines Tages auch nochmal.
Hinkommen. Ja.
Hinkommen. Bis dahin stellt er fest und er hat ja sicher jetzt die, also er sagt jetzt Zensur durch private darf es nicht geben,
Das ist auch sehr schön, darauf sollte man ihn auch nochmal festnageln. Aber das Löschen rechtswidriger in rechtswidriger Inhalte ist keine Zensur, sondern gleiches Recht für alle, analog und digital,
aber da wissen wir halt auch, rechtswidrige Inhalte äh sind oft nicht nur Meinungsäußerungen, ja, also löschen rechtswidriger Inhalte. Da haben wir eigentlich den Bezug zu diesen ähm,
anderen Rechten, die vielleicht noch irgendwo durchlöschen, durchgesetzt werden. Artikel sieben, der wird dann schon irgendwie spannender,
Jeder Mensch hat ein Recht darauf, dass seine Arbeit angemessen bezahlt wird, wenn er Dienstleistungen im Internet erbringt oder sie über das Internet vermittelt.
So, da denke ich mir jetzt erstmal so, wunderbar, wem stelle ich die Rechnung? Aber.
Ja, von was hat das jetzt mit dem Internet zu tun? Also das äh.
Schweine sagte, na ja, es gibt irgendwie viele Freiberufler und Solo-Selbstständige on demand. Das ist eigentlich ganz interessant, dass er da äh also im Prinzip auf diese Sharing-Economy eingeht, ne?
Schafft mehr Flexibilität, aber auch das Risiko zum digitalen Tagelöhner zu werden. Was? Sharing Economy,
schon ziemlich genau ist, ohne jede soziale Sicherheit.
Wobei ich es nicht finde, dass das Internet jetzt an der Stelle da äh als Brandbeschleuniger wirkt, sondern das ist eigentlich etwas, was wir in der Wirtschaft ohnehin schon haben.
Das ist ein richtiger äh richtiger Einwand, aber insbesondere in den letzten Jahren hast du natürlich so eine Entwicklung, die ähm die da nochmal irgendwie einen obendrauf setzt, ne. Ähm.
Und wenn,
Und wenn Arbeitsaufträge per Online-Auktion vergeben und Handwerker oder Haushaltshilfen in einen ruinösen Wettbewerb getrieben werden, dann brauchen wir ein Verbot.
Nicht genau wieso er dann noch im Internet dazu schreibt, also der.
Das wäre ja an sich äh ganz sinnvoll, unabhängig vom Internet.
Auch in der digitalen Welt muss es für eine gute Arbeit eine menschenwürdige Bezahlung geben. Also ich denke, hier hat er.
Also er sieht eine Verschärfung eines Problems durch das Netz, was aber nicht
an sich ein Problem des Netz an sich ist, sondern was einfach ein generelles Problem ist und auch schon in gewisser Hinsicht schon ist vorher schon abgezeichnet hat. Stimmt, dass dass äh das Internet jetzt hier auch die ähm Vorzeichen und die Faktoren nochmal ein bisschen ändert, aber,
Also weniger die Vorzeichen als Faktoren, ne? Ja. Ja.
Aber es war natürlich klar, wenn er über Vergütung im Internet redet, dann darf Artikel acht nicht fehlen. Alle Urheber,
Und ausübenden Künstler haben das Recht auf einen fairen Anteil an den Erträgen der digitalen Nutzung ihrer Werke. Das finde ich sowas von krasser. Einen fairen Anteil,
Es ist schon völlig, steht in dem Artikel schon drin, dass der Urheber nur einen Anteil kriegt,
Ja? Das finde ich also nehmen wir hier auf Bezug auf die letzte Woche, wo ich,
so ein bisschen gesagt habe, dass ich mich freuen würde, wenn Urheber direkt entlohnt würden und wir da möglichst wenig ähm
Mittelsmänner haben, die diese Domäne als ihren äh als ihre Industrie und ihre äh ihr Haupteinkommen sehen.
Sei es,
Apple mit einem App Store sei es äh Spotify, sei es Labels. Insgesamt würde ich mir eben wünschen, da weniger Mittelsmänner zu haben. In Artikel acht wird aber im Prinzip das schon zementiert,
Sagt dazu, noch nie hatten so viele Menschen zu so viel Wissen und Kultur so einfach Zugang wie heute, das hat er richtig erkannt,
Das verdanken wir der Digitalisierung, richtig. Zugleich ist geistiges Eigentum in der digitalen Welt besonders verletzlich geworden. Nach dem Grundsatz vergüten statt verbieten,
sollten vor allem neue Bezahlmodelle entwickelt werden, statt sich den Auswirkungen der Digitalisierung vergeblich entgegen zu stimmen. Lieber Heiko, da sagst du genau das, was ich eigentlich letzte Woche äh versucht habe, anzumerken.
Ja. Also gut.
Ich sehe, ich sehe jetzt deinen deine kritische Reaktion im Bezug auf fairer Anteil. Da sehe ich jetzt nicht unmittelbaren Brückenschlag zum Leistungsschutzrecht oder so äh fairer Anteil ist jetzt erstmal an sich keine.
Sehr aufgeladene Formulierung. Sagen wir's mal so, ja. Äh gut, neue Bezahlmodelle, ja, klar. Bitte,
bin,
Dabei ist interessant, dass wir hier sozusagen Urheberrecht dann auch gleich äh in der Liste der Grundrechte, die wir ja gerade hier diskutieren, sehen,
Ähm na gut, aber als Diskussionsgrundlage nehmen wir das mal auf.
Artikel neun ist schön.
Gibt's da auch noch so eine Zwischenüberschrift, ne?
Ja, die es zwischen wird. Wir sind noch nicht mal ein Satz.
Die Macht-Asymmetrie zwischen Normalbürgern und den Internetgiganten.
Ja, wunderbar, ich meine, das ist eine Sache, der man sich annehmen muss, ja? Hat er schon recht. Artikel neun sagte dann, der Staat gewährleistet die Netzneutralität. Ja, das wäre schön. Das wäre schön gewesen.
Das wäre schön gewesen. Mhm.
Gleichheit im digitalen Zeitalter bedeutet vor allem Netzneutralität. Das heißt, alle Datenpakete müssen mit der gleichen Geschwindigkeit und Qualität übertragen werden.
Er nimmt hier die radikale ähm Definition von Netzneutralität. Ähm wie gesagt,
die Realopposition sagt durchaus, dass man aufgrund von Diensten ähm.
Diskrim oder nicht, aber dass man Dienste unterschiedlich behandeln kann im Sinne einer Qualitätsoptimierung, aber eben nicht in Abhängigkeit von Anbietern, ja, also Netzneutralität ist eigentlich ja, wie wir schon mehrmals herausgestellt haben, die,
der das Verhindern dieses zweiseitigen Marktes und der äh Troll unter der Brückefunktion, die ähm,
Netzbetreiber für sich in Anspruch nehmen. Weiter sagt er, wir brauchen ein offenes Internet, bei dem die Anbieter entscheiden,
Was ins Netz kommt und die Kunden, welche Inhalte sie wahrnehmen, aber nicht die Netzbetreiber, ne, genau das, was ich gerade gesagt habe,
Ein Zweiklasseninternet würde dazu führen, dass kommerzielle Inhalte noch mehr dominieren, aber wie die Videos der ägyptischen Bürgerrechtler mit den Übergriffen vom Tahirplatz wohl kaum gesehen hätten. Es ist gut, dass das Europaparlament sich grundsätzlich zur Netzneutralität bekannt hat,
Das Beispiel mit den Videos würde ich hier etwas als etwas unglücklich gewählt.
Das würde ich auch sagen, ja, weil.
Also gerade das, was, worauf er sich da bezieht, ist ja das, was ich, was eigentlich als.
Alles über die großen Plattform.
Facebook Revolution in die Geschichte eingegangen ungerechtfertigterweise als Facebook-Revolution in die Geschichte eingegangen ist. Aber ich meine, er muss natürlich hier auch mal ein bisschen dick Butter aufs Brot schmieren für seinen Artikel neun.
Ja und das äh, ich meine, die Formulierung ist, es ist gut, dass das Europaparlament sich grundsätzlich zuletzt Neutralität
bekannt hat. Das ist schön, aber es ist schade, dass die EU-Kommission und der Rat, äh dem er ja sozusagen direkt auch angehört, äh leider das Gegenteil durchgesetzt hat und von daher muss ich sagen, ja, schöne Idee, Artikel neun, ähm,
Schön, dass wir darüber gesprochen haben, aber es findet leider gerade nicht statt und da könnt ihr euch auch selber nochmal ein bisschen am Kragen zupfen.
Artikel zehn. Niemand darf seine wirtschaftliche Macht missbrauchen. Der Staat verhindert Monopole und Kartelle, er fördert Vielfalt und Wettbewerb.
Ja, das ist eine eine Grundnotwendigkeit, wenn in einer Mischung aus äh Demokratie und Kapitalismus,
Dass man sagt, okay, dann, wenn wir schon das haben, dann müssen wir irgendwie immer wieder Monopole verhindern, weil die sich eben auch automatisch,
sonst ergeben. Als Beispiel sagt er, wenn Edeka und Tengelmann fusionieren wollen, dann schreitet schreiten unsere Kartellwächter ein, damit es auch künftig Wettbewerb zwischen den Supermärkten gibt.
Was tun wir aber, wenn und das ist klar, Google in Deutschland fünfundneunzig Prozent aller Suchanfragen abwickelt. Bei diesem Quasimonopol,
sollte eine Neutralität sichergestellt sein, damit alle Angebote diskriminierungsfrei auffindbar sind.
Um den Wettbewerb zu fördern und neuen Anbietern bessere Marktchancen zu geben, brauchen wir auch mehr Datenportabilität,
also das Recht, die eigenen Daten beim Wechsel eines Anbieters mitzunehmen,
Außerdem sind offene Schnittstellen und Interopeabilität notwendig, damit man Produkte verschiedener Anbieter an seinen äh Grenzen, an seinen Geräten nutzen kann. Die Welt besteht nicht nur aus Apple Produkten,
Tim, ganz ruhig.
Vorher hat er das.
Auch hier natürlich erstmal schöne Worte, aber wir wissen, ähm diese das Beispiel, was er hier wählt, ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig, mit diesem Quasi-Monopol Google, ja, weil man immer wieder, was immer wieder aus der Politik auch diese Forderung kommt, ja, Google manipuliert,
Sein Suchalgorithmus, ja. Äh als wäre der Suchalgorithmus von Google in irgendeiner Form ein neutrales Etwas.
Ja, ein, eine, eine objektive Waage, die nicht vollständig in,
in tausendfacher Weise äh manipuliert ist, ja? Darüber hatten wir auch vor in einer etwas länger vorangegangenen Sendung gesprochen,
Die Google Suchergebnisse sind stark, manipuliert und zwar dahingehend, dass sie den Menschen gefallen, die die Suchmaschine nutzen,
ähm schwierig da zu sagen, ich glaube die Forderung damals kam auch sogar von Heiko Maas oder von wem kam die zu sagen, Google müsse jetzt mal den Algorithmus offenlegen? Das war ein, zwei Jahre her. Haben sie gesagt, jetzt muss Google den Algorithmus.
Von wem das kam, ja.
Also,
geht. Ja, und da steht dann irgendwie eine Zeile drin und dann kam kann man nachher sagen, das und das ist irgendwie nicht äh nicht gerecht, ne? Also so geht es halt leider nicht, auch wenn es schön wäre,
Aber ich glaube, wo was er hier meint, ist eben,
Da hat man durchaus da muss man ein ein juristischen Angriffspunkt haben, sich in den nachweisbaren Fällen auch zur Wehr zu setzen, ja.
Also zu sagen.
Datenportabilität sicherzustellen und bei Quasimonopolen eine Neutralität sicherzustellen, das ist schon äh,
Das trifft schon einen Problempunkt, ja? Also wir erinnern uns an die vielen Fälle der der vergangenen Monate, ja, irgendwie Amazon verkauft irgendwas nicht mehr, Apple lässt zufällig unsere App nicht in den äh in den Store, ähm das wäre schon schön, da,
irgendwann auch mal eine äh Handhabe zu haben.
Also das ist hier, sagen wir mal, als Forderung ganz interessant.
Allerdings ist das auch wirklich ein Bereich, in dem herzlich wenig passiert. Gerade dieses Google Beispiel und insbesondere der Hinweis auf Suchmaschinen. Ist ja nun mehr als nur eine Suchmaschine,
Was tut denn bitte schön, Europa um diese Situation? Auch nur ansatzweise zu verbessern. Wenig bis gar nichts,
und ich denke, hier ist noch am meisten Hub. So, weil das ist einfach komplett unbeackerter Bereich für meinen Geschmack,
Vielfalt und Wettbewerb äh und in irgendeiner Form einer nennenswerten Unterstützung ähm,
der Basis, auf der man solchen Trends auch etwas entgegensetzen könnte, davon sehe ich halt einfach wenig bis gar nichts,
Es gab mal, ich habe jetzt eben grad nochmal geguckt, ich find's grad mal wieder nicht, wie es heißt, aber aufm äh Abend, auf dem netzpolitischen Abend hier in Berlin,
Projekt vorgestellt. Ich glaube, es hieß europäischer Index.
Ein Projekt, was die Idee äh voranträgt, äh doch auf europäischer Ebene,
quasi ein zu etablieren, um einfach die Basis für eine Suchmaschine zu schaffen. Und das einfach auch öffentlich zugänglich zu machen,
Solche Ideen, ich will das jetzt nicht als einzige Lösung hinstellen, sondern das sagen wir mal äh eine Idee in diesem Geiße, die ich äh sehr unterstützenswert finde, dass man sagt, okay, ja, wir sehen auch ein, dass das so eine
technische Leistungen wie Google sie gemacht hat mit wir durchsuchen das ganze Netz und wir bieten darauf noch 'ne Suchmaschine ja das lässt sich in dem Sinne heute nicht mehr so ohne weiteres wiederholen,
Sieht man ja, wie andere große Unternehmen da schon ihre Probleme haben, da auch nur ansatzweise mitzuziehen, aber in dem Moment, wo man das eben auf eine öffentliche Basis ziehen würde, würde man eben tatsächlich Vielfalt und Wettbewerb auch konkret fördern. Das wäre etwas, wo man Artikel zehn dann nochmal aus der Hosentasche ziehen kann.
Artikel elf. Jeder Mensch hat ein Recht auf Datensicherheit. Das ist sportlich, denn dieses Recht äh besteht, glaube ich, für die Wenigsten im Moment.
Dort ein bisschen drauf an, was Datensicherheit meint.
Genau, ne,
wird der natürlich auch direkt schwammig. Die enorme Bedeutung der Datenverarbeitung macht unser Gemeinwesen verwundbar und erhöht die Gefahr, dass sensible Daten in falsche Hände geraten. Der Terror ist längst auch im Netz angekommen.
Früher waren Hacker die Teenager-Nerds von nebenan. Heute gehen die Cyber-Attacken von kriminellen Terroristen oder fremden Geheimdiensten aus.
Wer sensible Daten speichert oder digitale Dienstleistungen der Daseinsvorsorge erbringt, muss diese kritische Infrastruktur auch besonders sichern. Datensicherheit ist Grundrecht und Grundpflicht. Bei Smartcards, Smart Cars
Also vernetzten Fahrzeugen wird sie sogar lebenswichtig werden. Ja, also.
Nicht nur da.
Wir haben dieses äh Grundrecht auf Integrität unserer Informationsverarbeitenden Systeme,
Und ich erinnere daran, dass wir im Januar, Februar diesen äh des kommenden Jahres uns dann wieder mit Staatstrojanern auseinandersetzen werden. Da dürfen wir den Heiko Mastern einen Artikel elf erinnern und damit äh diese Debatte dann hoffentlich
zum Erliegen bringen. Insofern können wir uns direkt Artikel zwölf zuwenden.
Genau. Bei uns bei den Teenagern Nerds von nebenan.
Ja ja.
Das sind doch wir ordentlich. Ja. Die Teenage-Nerds von dem Mann, sehr schön.
Artikel zwölf, die Staaten schaffen ein Völkerrechtes Netzes, um die Freiheit des Internets weltweit zu sichern.
Ist ganz interessant. Ich meine, bis jetzt hat die Freiheit des Internet sich immer gegen die Staaten äh verteidigen müssen, aber deswegen finde ich's gut, dass jetzt die Staaten sich schützens vor das Internet stellen, um uns vor wem genau zu schützen?
Seit Edward Snowden und dem NSA-Skandal wissen wir, dass der digitale Leviatan nicht nur im Silicon Valley lauert, auch Staaten bleiben eine Gefahr für die Freiheit, wenn sie an den Knotenpunkt des Internets ungezügelt E-Mails mitlesen oder unser Surfverhalten ausspähen.
Das Völkerrecht wurde vor vierhundert Jahren geschaffen, um die Freiheit der Meere zu sichern. Die Weltmeere des digitalen Zeitalters, das ist das Internet.
Deshalb brauchen wir eine internationale Verständigung über die Achtung persönlicher Daten, um sie vor dem willkürlichen Zugriff von Geheimdiensten zu schützen.
Wow. Heiko Maas hat sogar Illuminatus gelesen.
Oder seinen Mitarbeiter starb.
Kann auch sein, aber das ist mit dem digitalen kommt, das finde ich ja schon bemerkenswert. Ja, ähm gehen wir mit?
Oder?
Ja, ja, es ist natürlich nur eine Hälfte der der Problematik, aber eben auch die politisch zu lösende, ne? Also.
Ja, aber es wäre sicherlich ähm also ich finde den Gedanken finde ich absolut richtig und auch die ähm,
Sagen, dieser Freiheit der Meere äh von von den Freiheit der Meeren zu den Freiheit in den Datenmeeren. Das äh finde ich eine ganz brauchbare Analogie.
Thomas Hobs äh bedankt sich für die Referenz.
Ähm.
Das ist ein Standardwerk der Politikwissenschaft. Oder Stoffform und Gewalt eines kirchlichen und staatlichen Gemeinwesens.
Okay. Hatte ich nicht.
Oh, das ist äh ja, dann können wir das mal hier empfehlen. Das müsste inzwischen wahrscheinlich gemeinfrei sein, aber irgendjemand wird's sicherlich irgendwo nur. Ich gucke mal, ob man das irgendwo im Projekt Gutenberg oder so findet,
vielleicht auch vielleicht hat's auch irgendjemand verhindert, der Leviatan selbst vielleicht sogar.
Auch der braucht einen fairen Anteil.
Das heißt, Deleviatan ist da halt der der herrschende, der souverän.
Ähm der aber auch in einer anderen Weise eben gezügelt werden muss und so weiter. Na ja. Artikel.
Das Datenseemonster.
Artikel dreizehn.
Jeder Mensch hat das Recht auf eine analoge Welt. Niemand darf ungerechtfertigt benachteiligt werden, weil er digitale Dienstleistungen nicht nutzt.
Freiheit hat stets auch eine negative Dimension und gibt uns das Recht etwas nicht zu tun. Das muss auch im Zeitalter der Digitalisierung gelten. Eine Fahrkarte kaufen, einen Reisepass beantragen,
Eine Kontoüberweisung vornehmen, so etwas muss auch möglich bleiben ohne ein teures Smartphone zu kaufen?
Und es darf auch niemand benachteiligt werden, weil er keinen Facebook-Account besitzt. Das persönlich ist mir auch wichtig, muss ich sagen. Da,
Das ist nicht nur ein Minderheitenrecht für alle Digitalverwaltung, sondern auch ein Gebot der sozialen Gerechtigkeit. Zum Beispiel im Interesse von vielen Senioren, die teilen, die keine digital Natives mehr werden.
Irgendwie in Berlin allen Leuten sagen, die versuchen einen Termin bei einer Börse zu bekommen,
Na ja, da kannst du nur noch irgendwie im Internet dir dann deinen Termin klicken. Nee, ja, stimmt nicht, du kannst auch noch äh Telefonanruf machen.
Also er führt das noch weiter aus. Äh denke ich,
ist auch in Ordnung. Ja, natürlich sollte man jetzt keinen in die Digitalisierung zwingen und äh ihn zum Objekt eines Algorithmus werden lassen. Insofern kann man diesen,
Bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, wie er denn aus diesem Artikel noch irgendwas Böses rauskratzen will. Denn an dieser Kater wird sich ähm Heiko Maas dann in den kommenden,
Monaten und Jahren ähm in seinem Handeln messen lassen. Da bin ich mal sehr gespannt, äh,
ob er es wirklich schafft, in allen dreizehn Punkten noch umzukippen oder ob uns ein bisschen was davon erhalten bleiben wird.
Na ja, ist ja auch nicht ganz so alleine da in diesem ganzen äh Apparat, muss man auch mal dazu sagen.
Also du wirst wahrscheinlich niemanden finden in der gesamten Bundesregierung, der irgendwie seine persönliche Agenda mal in vierzehn, fünfzehn Artikel aufschreibt, der diese dann auch vollständig umgesetzt bekommt im Rahmen seiner Tätigkeit.
Ich frage mir, wenn du dir diese dreizehn Artikel anguckst, ne und dann nimmst du dir mal irgend so ein äh irgend so ein radikal radikal so einen christlichen Radikalfundamentalisten, ja?
Beckstein oder sowas, ne? Oder U. Welchen dieser Artikel würden die widersprechen? Das wäre der interessante Punkt.
Und äh ich glaube, höchstens irgendwie bei der Staat gewährleistet die Netzneutralität kann er mit direktem
Widerspruch rechnen. Die anderen Artikel werden die führen die glaub ich mittragen,
und oder sogar auch bei bei Netzneutralität machen sie das Gleiche, die würden jeden einzelnen dieser Artikel mittragen und ähm mit dem Hinweis, Ausnahmen regelt ein Gesetz, ähm,
versehen und dann kannst du das so stehen lassen.
Du meinst, sie wären auch für freie Meinungsäußerungen und so?
Natürlich, ich meine, er sagt ja, bei der freien Meinungsäußerung schiebt er ja direkt sechs nach, äh
allgemeine Gesetze und Persönlichkeitsrecht und die allgemeinen Gesetze bestimmen ja die C-Politiker. Insofern,
Glaube ich, ich glaube nicht, dass die einem dieser Artikel direkt,
widersprechen würden. Sie werden diesen Artikel, diese Artikel einschränken und in ihrem Handeln widersprechen, aber sie werden sich nicht hinstellen und sagen, ich widerspreche der digitalen Grundrechte Kater von Mars.
Oder findest du einen?
Ich überlege grade, Artikel zwölf, weiß ich nicht, Völkerrecht äh zur Absicherung der Freiheiten im Internet
Ob da jetzt jeder so äh mitgeht und ähm sozusagen in den Geheimdiensten, den digitalen Liviatan sieht. Äh ich glaube, da geht jetzt nicht unbedingt jeder sofort mit,
aber Artikel dreizehn ist auf jeden Fall ein Fest, ne. Mit der analogen Welt.
Also ich, wie gesagt, muss kann man ja auch als als äh Hausaufgabe für die Interessierten Hörer überlassen äh ich finde da jetzt erstmal spontan.
Oder? Schon recht. Also äh es klingt alles erst mal richtig, aber es ähm,
Klingt auch nicht so, als ob da nicht jeder mitgeben könnte. Will er auf jeden Fall mal interessant zu sehen, ob irgendjemand daran konkret irgendwas auszusetzen hat, obwohl es noch relativ schäumig formuliert ist. Aber ich finde es, ich finde es gut, dass er sowas auch formuliert.
Ich finde es überhaupt gut, wenn äh Politiker, die auch in so konkreten Ministerpositionen sitzen und weiß Gott eine Menge zu tun haben,
sich auch, sagen wir mal, zu solchen philosophischen Auslassungen bemüßigt fühlen.
Und hier sozusagen auch an einer Debatte, in einem, einem, einem öffentlichen Diskurs teilnehmen,
weil dann könnten sie auch bleiben lassen. Das steht ja jetzt sozusagen nicht in der Aufgabenbeschreibung eines Justizministers. Du sollst öffentliche Debatten über Inside Online äh anstoßen,
und macht ja auch nicht jeder.
Na, du musst aber irgendwie deine also, wie gesagt, lass sie mal abwarten, was wir von dem Mann noch sehen. Ich finde das auf jeden Fall mal ganz gut, jetzt noch mal was zu haben, woran man ihn erinnern kann.
So, das ist also diese geheime Keynote. Jetzt hast du's ausgeplaudert.
Über die Vorratsdaten.
Und warum das gut ist für uns Teenager.
Kief Alexander und Heiko Maas. So ähm.
Ja, die können sich da mal so ein Rap Battle geben.
Wir haben ja im Freifunkbereich so ein paar Verfahren.
Neues Thema, wa?
Das ist ein neues Thema. Und da gibt's jetzt vor dem Münchner Landgericht eines ein Verfahren eines Freifunnkers, der
sich gegen Ansprüche von Sony Music wert. Also, was passiert ist? Der hat halt offenes WLAN angeboten, hat dann irgendwie eine Abmahnung von Sony Music bekommen, hat gesagt, hier nix. Äh die wollten halt irgendwie achthundert Euro von ihm haben und dann hat er gesagt, nix äh ich habe hier freies WLAN angeboten. Ich
äh für mich gilt diese äh für mich gilt eine Haftungsfreistellung und er,
hat dann eine äh negative Feststellungsklage angestrengt, ja? Also sich nicht nur gegen die Abmahnung gewehrt, sondern eben auch gegen Sony Music geklagt und,
Das Landgericht geht davon aus,
dass eben Dritte die Urheberrechtsverletzung begangen haben und eben nicht der äh Tobias McFaden selbst,
und will deshalb wissen, ob EU-Gesetze,
Verantwortlichkeit des des WLAN-Betreibers, also Tobias McVetten, ausschließen. Und zur Klärung dieser Frage hat sie den Fall, an den Europäischen Rechtshof nach Luxemburg geworfen.
Genau, das kennen wir ja jetzt sozusagen auch schon aus den äh anderen ähm Timmfeldern, die wir jetzt jüngst äh diskutiert haben,
Man kann sich nicht direkt ähm an das EUGH wenden, aber man kann es sozusagen dorthin äh eskalieren.
Genau und das ist hier geschehen und da könnte man jetzt hoffen, ähm
die Argumentation der klagenden Partei ist, wenn WLAN-Hotspots generell zwangsweise verschlüsselt werden müssten, hätte das eben auch zur Folge, dass sich jegliches, öffentliches WLAN in öffentlichen Einrichtungen, Geschäftszentren, Beherbungsbetrieb Beherbergungsbetrieben, Gaststätten, Museen
in ein privates WLAN veröffentlichen äh verwandeln würde. Also quasi sagen,
wenn du keine öffentlichen Wählern betreiben darfst, dann ist der Schaden sehr groß für alle,
Und äh da wollen sie offenbar die äh,
Rechtsgüter abwägen lassen, um zu sagen, okay, gibt's da, gibt's dafür eine Handhabe, die sind Schaden ein, anzurichten, hauptsächlich um durch die durch diese Störerhaftung,
die in der Regel einfach nur den Interessen der äh Verwertungsindustrie äh dient. Nun sagen sie,
Es ist auch nicht angemessen, Anbieter eines Hotspots zu Verhinderung von Urheberrechtsverletzungen zu verurteilen und ihnen die Wahl der Mittel zu überlassen.
Ja? Wie es in der momentanen, gängigen Rechtsprechung eben passiert. Im Zweifelsfall würde nämlich der WLAN Dienste Anbieter übertriebene Maßnahmen ergreifen, um eine Haftung auszuschließen, dass er genau das, was wir jetzt auch sehen.
Ich kann gerade nicht so äh ganz folgen. Das ist jetzt die Meinung des des Landgerichts noch.
Nee, das ist die Meinung der äh Klagenden. Das Landgericht hat gar keine Meinung, sondern hat gesagt, das müssen wir erstmal auf auf EuGH-Ebene äh klären.
Okay, also sozusagen jetzt die äh okay, die meinen.
Ja? Dann sagen sie im Zweifelsfall würde nämlich der Wlan Anbieter übertriebene Maßnahmen ergreifen, um seine Haftung auszuschließen,
was sich auf die Grundrechte des Nutzers im Hinblick auf den Datenschutz und die Informationsfreiheit negativ auswirke. Ist eine, denke ich, eine sehr,
Kluge und gültige valide Argumentation zu sagen, okay, was, wenn ihr die Haftung auf den WLAN Zugangsanbieter drückt,
dann wird der um der Haftung zu entgehen übermäßige Maßnahmen ergreifen,
Und diese übermäßigen Maßnahmen werden in einer Einschränkung der Informationsfreiheit des Nutzers. Resultieren und deswegen,
argumentieren sie eben grundsätzlich gegen die Störerhaftung, weil sie sagen, der freie Zugang zu dem Netz, ist das höhere Gut als hier irgendwie eine Zustellungsadresse für überhöhte ähm Abmahnungen zu haben.
Wir werden sehen, was wieder EuGH da entscheidet, ist auf jeden Fall interessant, da ist so eine
negative Feststellungsklage. Jetzt wirklich auch mal bis vor den EuGH kommt. Das äh äh ist erstmal als Erfolg zu ähm werten. Wir werden sehen, für wen.
Ja, es könnte natürlich auch wieder zu so einer interessanten Grundsatzentscheidung äh führen, die dann von allen europäischen Ländern ignoriert wird.
Gut. Viel EU äh heute. Man merkt, dass äh die Bedeutung zunimmt.
Hier hat die EU-Kommission hat jetzt angekündigt, sich mal um das Urheberrecht zu kümmern.
Und als erstes äh wie haben sie das genannt, als Vorspeise? Haben sie gesagt,
Wir werden dafür sorgen, eines der größten Probleme, unter denen das Internet leidet, jetzt mal sofort zu lösen, nämlich den Zugang zu Streaming-Diensten und anderen digitalen Inhalten zeitweilig aus dem Ausland,
Also Klassiker, du bist irgendwie äh was weiß ich, du möchtest zum Beispiel die ARD-Mediathek gucken, ja, mit Hilfe des weltumspannenden Datennetzes
Möchtest du die Gelegenheit nutzen, auch in deinem Urlaub oder auf deiner Geschäftsreise mal den Tatort aus der ARD-Mediathek zu sehen.
Nein. Ne.
Gar nicht. Erstens hast du da diese Zeitsperren, die sagen, es na, ist noch nicht nach zwanzig Uhr,
darfst du nicht gucken. Und zweitens hast du dann noch diese Sperren, die sagen, du bist ja gar nicht in Deutschland, ja.
Auf Mallorca, ne?
So und da sagen sie halt, ja, also zeitweilig wollen wir da eine Lösung finden. Ja, dass also auch die armen Leute, die ein Netflix-Abo haben,
was weiß ich hasse,
Netflix Abo fließt nach Indien, in Indien gibt's kein Netflix, kannst deine Serien nicht zu Ende gucken, ne. Brauchst du irgendwie, musst du musst du dir ein VPN klicken oder ähm,
oder so ein äh,
DNS-Server äh eingeben, der dann halt andere, der die andere IP-Adresse ausgibt, damit du doch noch Netflix gucken kannst. Trick ist, du holst dir ein VPN nach Schweden, weil dann hast du schwedisches Netflix, da gibt's sogar nochmal irgendwie ein paar Serien mehr oder so.
Es geht natürlich so alles nicht. Das ist also jetzt schon mal der das dicke Bonbon, was uns die EU-Kommission verspricht,
Und äh möchte außerdem dann in Zukunft uns noch äh mehrere Ausnahmeregelungen im Urheberrecht zugunsten von Blinden und Sehbehinderten schenken. Das ist natürlich immer gut,
und ähm,
In dieser Form wollen sie eben ihre Verpflichtung aus dem internationalen Blindenvertrag umsetzen, den die Staaten der Welturheberrechtsorganisationen bereits zweitausenddreizehn beschlossen hatten.
Und natürlich im Bildungsbereich wollen sie sich auch noch ein bisschen umschauen. Die Julia Räder, die wir ja,
beim Camp auch zu Gast hatten, hat äh sich diesen Kommissionsentwurf mal angeschaut und hat auf ihrem Blog eine äh Score-Card ähm.
Veröffentlicht, wo sie im Prinzip sagt, so welche Echos, wie adressiert werden,
Wenn sie sagt, ich will da jetzt nicht äh nicht alle von durchgehen, aber diese Geoblocking-Sache kritisiert sie natürlich auch und sagt, na ja, okay, das soll jetzt irgendwie nur hier auf äh auf temporär sein
und das ist irgendwie Kritik würdig, weil es eben,
Ne, irgendwie nicht dauerhaft ist und sie will ja eigentlich Geoblocking vollständig loswerden, ist ein sagt, ist ein erster Schritt in die richtige Richtung, aber was sie eigentlich möchte, ähm,
ist, dass das Geoblocking vollständig wegkommt und was was die Kommission hier verspricht, ist im Prinzip äh äh Roaming für Netflix. Das ist das, was sie eigentlich sagen. Also Netflix, äh die deine Kunden müssen roman dürfen, ne, für zwei, drei Wochen.
Ähm.
Panoramafreiheit war hier so ein Anliegen, da sagt sie, okay, da hat gibt's ein klares Bekenntnis. Der Kommission zu ähm.
Es gibt auch ein klares Bekenntnis dazu, Werke, die nicht weiter, die nicht weiter verkauft werden, auch zugänglich zu machen, ja? Dass du quasi durch,
nicht, nicht durch, nicht neu Auflage, die Verbreitung von Werken einschränken kannst. Sie möchte ähm sie möchten die Bildung,
die Bildungspolitik stärken, sie möchten die Nutzerrechte für digitale Inhalte
stärken und das sind jetzt so die positiven Punkte, aber sie hat eine relativ lange Liste der der roten und gelben Punkte, wo sie äh nicht glücklich und zufrieden ist und ich denke, wir werden einfach mal die Gelegenheit nutzen, da zeitnah mit ihr nochmal drüber zu sprechen, wenn die Kommission
ihren großen, geschwungenen Worten erste ernsthaft niedergeschriebenen äh Vorschläge ähm,
folgen lässt.
Mhm, schöne, schöne.
Das ist eine sehr gute Aufarbeitung, ja.
Ist es wirklich also der der Style gefällt mir einfach sehr gut, weil er irgendwie extrem äh klar fokussiert ist. Man kann hier sehr schnell, also erstmal sieht man sozusagen ihre ähm nicht nur ihre Gewichtung, sondern sozusagen auch ihre,
Tour ihrer Strukturierung sozusagen dieser Themen und äh geht das dann einzeln äh durch, bewertet es unabhängig voneinander und das äh ja, ist super, nicht gut.
Ja, das ist sehr, sehr gut aufbereitet und deswegen äh empfehlen wir, dass diesen Link zu klicken.
Genau, klicken sie diesen Link jetzt.
Und sie weist natürlich auch darauf hin, dass man sich immer noch an die äh Kommission wendet, weil sie ja ähm.
Quasi noch die Sicht der Nutzer ähm,
Willkommen heißt, da gibt's also eine Möglichkeit, sich an dieser Umfrage zu befinden. Und äh sich an dieser Umfrage zu beteiligen und diesen Link hat sie äh unter ihrem Artikel und wir haben den auch ähm bei uns in den Shownots.
Bleiben wir noch ein bisschen beim Urheberrecht, oder?
Unbedingt.
Wir haben gerade schon darüber gesprochen, dass die äh EU Kommission zumindest, sage ich mal, Ausnahmeregelung und Erleichterung in im Urheberrecht,
Anstrebt äh im Bereich der Bildung,
Währenddessen haben wir in Deutschland ähm die Verwertungsgesellschaft Wort,
die ein Zusammenschluss von Autoren und Verlagen ist, der Tanthemen aus Zweitnutzungsrechten einnimmt und an die Urheber weitergibt. Ich kannte die VG-Wort,
vor allem daher, dass man so bei Netzpolitik org zum Beispiel ein Zählpixel äh eingebaut hat,
und da gibst du quasi als Autor deine ähm deine VG Wort Mitgliedsnummer ein.
Und.
Dann zählt die VG Wort quasi mit, dass oder wie oft deine Artikel gelesen wurden? Und dann kannst du dir am Ende nachher dafür Geld geben lassen.
Man muss sich auf der VG Wort, man kann sich da so eine Karteinummer geben lassen und wenn man das irgendwie in bei dann in die in das Blog einbaut, dann kriegt man am Ende des Jahres irgendwie Geld. Weil die, weil man ja Autor ist und die VW Wort,
entlohnt dann den Autor.
Ist tatsächlich etwas, was auch bei äh Netzpolitik org zumindest mal genutzt wurde. Auch wenn ich im Quelltext jetzt gerade erst auf die Schnelle nicht gefunden habe, aber so, daher kannte ich eigentlich immer die VG Wort. Stellt sich aber raus, die Vogelwort.
Hat natürlich überall ihre äh Finger im Spiel, wo etwas gelesen wird. Und bisher war das,
bei den Universitäten so.
Diejenigen von uns, die mal irgendwie eine Uni besucht haben, erinnern sich oder die gerade eine Uni besuchen, dass es da häufig so ist, dass Professoren ein Skript zur Vorlesung bereitstellen? Da hast du dann irgendwie.
Vielleicht mal ein paar Buchseiten drin kopiert
Oder man wissenschaftlichen Artikel und dann kannst du in gehst in Copy Shop und holst dir diesen Reader oder so, ne? Bei manchen Seminaren sind das dann lecker mal irgendwie fünfhundert bis tausend Seiten für so ein Semester oder so,
Wallose Zusammenglaubung von Artikeln und ähm.
Buchkapiteln oder was auch immer, äh die Professoren in der freien Ausübung ihrer Lehre für die Studierenden für relevant halten. Und die Basis dafür war.
Dass die ähm Unis so eine Art ähm,
Pauschalabgabe gezahlt haben an die VG-Wort. Ja, die haben einfach gesagt, okay, wir machen das und dafür, dass wir das machen, zahlen wir euch folgenden Betrag.
Und jetzt hat die VG Wort aber gerichtlich erstritten, dass jede Seite aus einem Skript einzeln gemeldet und bezahlt werden muss.
In dem Fall, dass es,
online bereitgestellt wird. Das scheint hier mein äh so, wenn es digital von der Uni bereitgestellt wird. Und das gilt selbst dann, wenn das Skript vom Dozenten Passwort geschützt nur eine Handvoll Seminarteilnehmern zugänglich gemacht wird.
Ja, Artikel acht. Fairer Anteil an den Erträgen.
Ja, weißt du, was für ein Reibach gemacht wird von den Studenten? Ja, die verdienen sich dumm und duselig. Ja. Während ihrer Ausbildung und äh das kann einfach nicht sein,
Dass da nicht einfach auch ein fairer Anteil gezahlt wird. Also ich halte das für wirklich absurd. Also ich finde es erstmal schon mal absurd, dass die VG Wort sich überhaupt in so einen juristische äh Bereich gegeben hat.
Also was möchten sie bitte darin gewinnen?
Geld.
Ja, ja, aber ich meine, es ist nicht durchführbar.
Nee, eben und das ist genau das, was passieren wird. Also sie sagen im Prinzip so, na ja, okay, ab jetzt müsst ihr uns seitenweise Rechenschaft ablegen über das, was ihr in euren Skripten in geschützten Bereichen einem kleinen Nutzerkreis zugänglich macht und es das alles
melden. Das heißt im Prinzip die Professoren und äh die Unis haben einen bürokratischen Aufwand vor sich, den sie nicht leisten können,
und das könnte dann ultimativ bedeuten, dass äh die Professoren und Dozenten einfach ganz oder,
Einfach ganz darauf äh verzichten. Skripte äh digital bereitzustellen. Ja, vielleicht
gibt's dann den, den Fall, dass sie sagen, okay, komm, wir machen das irgendwie mit Papierkopien. Ich glaube, diese Regelung bezieht sich eben erstmal,
Wenn ich das hier richtig lese, nur auf digitale Bereitstellung.
Aber so wie, ich meine, die letzten in den letzten zehn Jahren hat man als als Studierender ähm,
Wahrscheinlich wohlwollend die zehn Bemühungen,
beobachtet, sowas in dieser durchaus nicht perfekten, aber immerhin immer weiter verbreiteten Lernplattformen Mode abzubilden, wurde man dann eben auch mal sehen kann, für diese Woche hat äh,
Der oder die Dozierende eine
einen Artikel bereitgelegt, das ist ein PDF, das hat die irgendwo runtergeladen, vielleicht auch von weiß der Geier, wo sie's her haben, das muss auf jeden Fall gelesen werden, das möchten wir der nächsten Seminarstunde besprechen,
So und genau über genau dieser Akt muss dann jetzt eben dokumentiert und der VG Wort gemeldet werden. Also ich weiß nicht, ob den ganz klar ist, was das äh was das bedeuten wird, ja.
Grade auch wenn man sich überlegt, wie das im im Bildungsbereich mit den Disketten ist. Achtzig und so, ne.
Ja, also hier äh das also ich meine, sorry, so wenn wir wenn wir von unserem Universitätswesen irgendetwas haben wollen, dann muss das halt möglichst straff von dieser ganzen Urheberrechtsscheiße freigestellt werden. Das gilt nicht nur,
für oder eben zumindest sagen wir Pauschalvergütung, muss man sagen, okay, ne?
Pauschalvergütung in Ordnung, verteilt das wie ihr wollt. So, aber bitte ermöglicht die Freiheit der Lehre und der Ausbildung,
Ja, wenn ihr das, wenn wir das nicht machen, wird das ein riesiges Problem werden
wir haben das das Problem ist ja schon groß genug über durch diese großen Wissenschaftsverlage, die letztendlich, ja, ich habe das, glaube ich, schon mehrmals ausgeführt, aber die großen Wissenschaftsverlage machen nichts anderes als
Forschungsergebnisse der Universitäten in ihren Journals zu veröffentlichen,
und diese Journals dann den Universitäten wieder zurückzuverkaufen. Das ist das ist das, was diese Wissenschaftsver,
haben wir lange, große ähm Open Access Initiativen,
die sich darum kümmern, hier die Freiheit der Wissenschaft und die Freiheit der äh Lehre irgendwie wieder in diesen Betrieb zurückzubringen. Und es ist in diesem Bereich wirklich bitter, wenn.
Da äh durch solche,
Verwertungsrechte, denn muss ja nicht meinen, dass irgendeiner der Autoren, die in einem dieser wissenschaftlichen Journals veröffentlichen, dafür irgendwie eine nennenswerte Bezahlung bekäme,
ja, die Journals bezahlen ja auch nicht die Forschenden für die Forschung, die sie da veröffentlichen,
das Einzige, was diese Journals machen, ist, dass sie einen Stab bereithalten von kompetenten Personen, die die das Peer-Review machen. Das ist durchaus auch etwas, was im wissenschaftlichen Kontext ebenso notwendig ist,
und ähm wo auch.
Wobei dieser Stab nicht wirklich angestellt, diese Unternehmen sind, sondern andere Wissenschaftler, die das auch kostenlos machen.
Ist auch kostenlos machen und sich da und dann sich dafür geehrt werden, ne? Das schreibst du als Wissenschaftler schön in deinen CV, dass du im im
was weiß ich, Editer von einem Journal Biss oder regelmäßiger Reviewer für einen Journal oder so, dass auch immer eine Ehre, ne? Letztendlich,
werden ja die wenigsten Bereiche von von vielen Wissenschaftlern beackert, so dass wenn du dann,
Als Review äh benannt wirst, dann ist es auch auf eine gewisse Weise eine Ehre, dass dass du dem Editta eben,
als die Person bekannt bist, die über diese wissenschaftliche Arbeit das erste wichtige Urteil fällen soll.
Zweifel ist das dann so, also liegt ihr dann vor und dann liest ihr da durch und dann kannst du ein paar Fragen stellen, Verbesserungsvorschläge
dann geht das anonym an den Autoren zurück oder an die Autorin oder an das Autorenteam zurück und dann wird das umgesetzt oder nicht, dann wird dir das wieder vorgelegt und dann entscheidet der Edither,
ja? Aus dem Feedback der Reviewer und der den Änderungen, die dann da geschehen
sind, ob dieses Paper dann veröffentlicht wird oder nicht. Das ist durchaus, das ist eine wichtige Qualitätssicherungsmaßnahme in der Wissenschaft und es ist auch wichtig, dass das Journals sich bestimmte,
einen bestimmten Ruf erarbeiten, ja? Einfach damit du quasi ja,
eine Sortierung hast, auch als interessierter Leser oder anderer oder Lesende und Forscher in diesem Bereich, diese,
diese Leistung der Journets für die Wissenschaft will ich nicht in Abrede stellen, aber das das Geld, was die uns kosten
und unsere Universitäten kosten, das ist nicht mehr feierlich. Aber hier komme ich auch ein bisschen vom vom Thema ab. Ähm,
Das hier ist nicht gut. Das, was hier von der VG Wort erstritten.
Ja, ich freue mich vor allem, also ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das in diesem äh Urteil so klar auch dann schon herausgestellt wurde, aber was heißt denn künftig muss jede Seite aus einem Skript einzeln gemeldet werden?
Seite was, jede Seite eines Buches.
Jede Seite des Gürts. Von wem ist sie? Wo ist sie her? So, wer hat die geschrieben?
Ja und wie meldet man das dann? Wie referenziert man da drauf? Ich meine, wir haben immer noch äh was was haben wir, glaube ich, bisher auch so noch nie drüber gesprochen,
Aber was ich ja auch als ein Grundproblem ansehe in dieser ganzen Urheberrechtsverwertungsgeschichte ist, wir haben immer dieses,
Diese pauschale Geltung eines Urheberrechts, ja? Du schaffst irgendwas, du hast das Urheberrecht daran, ohne weitere Maßnahmen,
Ergreifen zu müssen.
Ein anderes vorstellbares Modell wäre ja, man sagt, okay, wir wir räumen den Urhebern die rechte ein, aber ihr habt eine Meldepflicht,
Ihr müsst euer urheberrechtlich geschütztes Werk auch als solches melden.
An einer irgendwie zu schaffenden äh Instanz und dann gibt's auch eine Nummer dafür.
Ja, das ist ja auch das, was die vorgeworden macht. Du hast als Urheber, als Autor eine Nummer, ja? Und genau das wollen sie ja.
Nein, nein, das Werk. Nein, nein, das Werk muss eine Nummer haben, weil du hast ja das Problem, wie wie.
Nee, ich glaube, die gehen auf Autorenbasis. Wenn ich det, also.
Ja, das kann ja sein, dass ihr auf.
Aufs dünne Eis, aber die kommen, die gehen nach Autorenbas.
Worauf ich hinaus will ist, die Arbeit, die man hat, um eine solche Meldung vorzunehmen.
Ja, was, was, was, was heißt das? Pro Seite, ich habe den und den und den Autor genannt, das reicht dann schon. Wissen wir nicht. Okay.
Also,
Ich kenne das Modell, was ich gerade geschildert habe. Ich weiß nicht, wie die VG Water das sonst macht. Aber ich würde hier vermuten, dass ihr Interesse ist, zu sehen, welche Autoren werden hier wie oft kopiert und welchen dieser Autoren müssen wir dann entsprechend auch die Tantieme geben?
Wird auch die das wird auch die Argumentation,
Der VG Wort an dieser Stelle gewesen sein, dass sie sagen, wenn wir diese Daten nicht haben, sondern eine Pauschal äh Vergabe bekommen, äh eine Pauschalvergütung äh bekommen, dann,
wir nicht dazu in der Lage ähm unsere Einnahmen.
Gerecht zu verteilen.
Zu verteilen. Das würde ich würde ich vermuten, dass das die Argumentation ist,
Dennoch beziehe ich mich darauf zurück, das Urteil habe ich nicht genau gelesen und das Entscheidende ist, dass das den Lehrbetrieb, das was, wenn es zu komplex wird.
Ja, dann hast du, vor allem, wenn du sagst, du willst es seitengenau haben, ja, dann äh wird es eben dazu führen, dass die Lehrenden an den Universitäten ihre Skripts nicht mehr bereitstellen können.
Und ich kenne das auch schon also wir das gibt's ja immer wieder an Universitäten, dass dann die Lehrenden sagen, ja es gibt da so eine gibt da so ein Buchkapitel und so äh müssten sie mal,
Ich gehe jetzt mal kurz aus dem Zimmer. So, hier liegt so ein USB-Stick. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo dieser USB-Stick herkommt. Äh,
Das wäre auch echt ärgerlich, wenn dir jetzt nachher jemand von ihnen hätte, aber ich muss jetzt echt dringend, also bitte so huch, wo ist denn der USB-Stick hin? So, ne, weil die da eben auch unter Druck sind, unter Druck stehen, ne.
Dass diese Problematik, da muss man eben äh abwägen und Lösungen finden und da halte ich eine Pauschalvergütung,
für das,
Wichtigere oder das bessere, auch wenn sie dann eben in den in Einzelfällen zu einer nicht hundertprozentig äh gerechten Verteilung der Tanthemen, die sicherlich auch wichtig sind für die für die Urhebenden, äh,
resultiert.
Also, das einzeln melden, da komme ich irgendwie noch so ein bisschen, da da kann ich noch mitgehen, ne?
Das ist ja das Problem, das werden die Universitäten nicht leisten können.
Ja ist nochmal ein anderer Aspekt so, aber hier heißt es ja auch einzeln bezahlen.
Das heißt, umso mehr ich nenne, umso mehr muss ich bezahlen.
Das könnte sozusagen da drinstehen, weil in dem Moment, wo ich keine pauschale Vergütung mehr habe, die sagt, hier ist der Betrag, damit ist alles abgegolten, ja,
der Wunsch sozusagen, noch mehr Tracking zu haben, was denn nun konkret zitiert wurde, was er nun konkret genutzt wurde, damit die ihren Schlüssel, der äh auf der dieses pauschal gezahlte Geld dann auch gerecht verteilt trainieren können,
Da gehe ich ja irgendwie noch mit. Das ist zwar natürlich auch schon dieser Aspekt, okay, hier kommt viel Arbeit auf uns zu. Ja, aber in dem Moment, wo sozusagen auch noch die Bezahlung da dranhängt,
Bedeutet das ja einerseits so aha umso mehr zitiert wird, umso mehr muss bezahlt werden. Da hast du halt schnell eine eine Unileitung, wie gesagt, der zitiert mal nicht so viel,
Das können wir nicht bezahlen, ja?
Weiß ja wie das ist. Also du hast an in dem Moment einfach ein ein nicht kalkulierbare Größe. Klar, die kannst du irgendwie schätzen, da hast du da irgendwie so dein Jahresbudget, aber dann wird dann einfach mal zitiert, wie nix Gutes und dann kommen sie halt irgendwann an und sagen, hier mal nicht so viel zitieren,
Ist ja nun, kann ja auch nicht die Antwort sagen.
Vor allem und das ist das nächste, was mir jetzt noch kommt. Ich meine, gut, hier dreht es sich vor allem um Texte, ne. Wir reden jetzt hier über die VG-Wort, aber grundsätzlich hätte das natürlich jetzt auch äh entsprechenden ähm,
Charakter auch für andere Medieninhalte,
Ja, was ist mit Bildern, was ist mit äh Fotografien, was ist mit Diagramm, was ist mit ähm was ist mit Videos?
Also im Unterrichtsmaterial insbesondere, zumal dieses, ich stelle ein Skript bereit für eine Vorlesung. Ich meine, das ist ja irgendwie auch noch so ein bisschen zwanzigstes Jahrhundert.
Worauf es jetzt hinausläuft, sind mittelfristig werden wir auch eine äh umfassende Änderung der Art und Weise haben, wie Lehrinhalte überhaupt vermittelt werden,
da fallen mir so Konzepte ein wie halt sozusagen diese ganzen,
Vorlesungen komplett umgedreht werden und primär überhaupt erstmal im Netz stattfinden, ja. Was ist denn mit solchen eingestellten Videos?
Können die dann irgendwie auch noch pauschal abgesichert werden oder kriege ich dann einfach eine Million YouTube Klicks und dann muss ich sozusagen für meine Vorlesung auch noch regelmäßig Geld bezahlen.
Das sind schon so Fragen, die man sich stellen muss.
Es sind Fragen, die man sich stellen muss. Ich denke aber, wie gesagt, man kann dieses ganze Problem hier nur dadurch in den Griff kriegen.
Die man zum Beispiel bisher.
Indem man das irgendwie pauschal löst und da den Bürokratieaufwand verringert, um eben diese Freiheit der Lehre und der Wissenschaft sicherzustellen.
Anders kann ich mir das einfach nicht vorstellen.
Meldung oder die Bezahlung.
Also, ich ich halte ernsthaft so, dass die Freiheit der Wissenschaft und der Lehre ist das höhere Gut als die Vergütung der Urheber. Die was da an Urhebern, was da an Urheberrechtlich geschützten Materialien verteilt wird,
In solchen Seminaren hat zu achtzig Prozent sowieso kein Urheberrecht,
Verwertung verdient, weil diese vor, in der Regel geht es daher um Forschung. Und diese Forschung ist bezahlt worden und wenn sie in Deutschland ähm erst durchgeführt wurde, dann ist sie von der öffentlichen Hand,
bezahlt worden. Das heißt, es sind Urheberrechte sollten da von vorne herein im wissenschaftlichen Bereich einfach überhaupt nicht bestehen,
Dafür unterhalten wir uns ja die Universitäten als freie Orte des Wissens und des Zugangs zu diesem Wissen. Er ist also von vornherein schon falsch, wissenschaftliche ähm,
Veröffentlichung mit einer derartigen ähm Verwertung,
Und Verwertungsmöglichkeit zu versehen.
Ja.
Ja, also da kann man im Detail noch weiter diskutieren, aber ist eben
grundsätzlich falsch. Ja, weil am Ende zahlst du das doppelt. Also du zahlst ist ernsthaft so, du zahlst als Universität am Ende für das
Abo von dem Journal, wo deine Professoren und Professorinnen mit zwei Jahre Arbeit, wenn sie Glück haben, mal einen Artikel drin platziert bekommen
damit du den am Ende bei dir ins Regal stellen kannst.
Wurde eine Professorin auch noch die Zeit dafür bereitgestellt haben aus ihrer normalen Arbeitszeit heraus das auch noch zu reviewen.
Genau. So und dann gab's am Ende dafür bezahlen,
Das ist das geht so nicht. Aber das ist jetzt, ne, sind zwei verschiedene Paar Schuhe. Einmal die wissenschaftlichen Verlage und dann eben die VG Wort, die ja hier eigentlich dienthemen der,
Der veröffentlichenden,
ähm sichern möchte, wo man hier dann zum Beispiel auch wiederum, wenn man weit gehen würde, das Argument bringen kann. Wieso, das ist doch bezahlt. Ich meine, diese Artikel zu veröffentlichen, diese Forschung durchzuführen, ist Teil der Aufgabenbeschreibung
der Forschenden, ja? Wobei ich denen auch unter ne, also
im Detail muss man da sicherlich nochmal drüber reden, aber ist auf jeden Fall das höhere Gut, dass äh Forschungen,
und Lehre hier möglichst frei sind und auch das Wissen, das sie generieren.
Gut, kommen wir zum Schluss.
Kommen wir zum Schluss, das Radar wird eingestellt vom ZDF und ist es nicht feierlich, welche Begründung sie dafür nennen,
Das ZDF hatte so einen Projekt namens Lobby Radar, das war ein oder ist ein äh Browser Plugin.
Dass die Verbindung von Politik und Lobbyisten aufzeigen soll. Hass dieses Plug-in irgendwie an, gehst auf eine Seite und dann,
quasi,
werden äh Namen unterstrichen und dann kannst du da drüber gehen, dann siehst du, welche Verbindungen diese Personen haben. Hier haben wir so einen Screenshot. Da ist dann irgendwie Elmar,
Wissen und dann siehst du, hat Verbindung zur Atlantikbrüche Brücke zur Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz zum RTL
äh zum ZDF zum äh International Press Institut und so weiter. Da kannst du halt quasi sehen, wie sind die,
In der Politik und der ähm in und dem Lobbyismus,
Verbunden. Prominenterweise dieses Beispiel, was ich gerade genannt habe, ist der ZDF-Chefredakteur und daher weht auch der Wind, denn dieses Projekt haben sie mit Open Data City äh realisiert,
Der Vertrag mit Open Data City läuft Ende des Jahres aus Open Deta City ist bekannt
war bei uns auch schon mal mehrmals zu Gast für viele interessante Projekte im Bereich der Datenvisualisierung.
Und ähm man geht laut Zeit ungefähr vom vom niedrigen sechsstelligen Betrag aus, den das ZDF bisher,
diese Initiative gesteckt hat. Und jetzt hat der offenbar der ZDF-Intendant Thomas Bellod gegen die Weiterführung entschieden.
Weil er gerne das Geld woanders investieren möchte, zum Beispiel in äh bei der Fußball-EM und in den gemeinsamen Jugendkanal mit der ARD. Und so, ja
und es werden aber Stimmen laut, die sagen, es gab einen, es hätte einen großen Druck gegeben,
ähm aus dem überwiegend mit Politikern besetzten ZDF-Rundfunkrat sowie aus weiteren Politikkreisen, weil die eben sich in ihrer in der Freiheit, ihrer Amtsausübung eingeschränkt gesehen haben, wenn da überall dieser Lobbyradar
ihre Verbindung zeigt uns hier. Ja, das war natürlich auch genau das Ziel. Es gab.
Wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Natürlich solche großen Datenmengen ähm.
Haben da auch immer mal wieder das kleine Problemchen, dass äh sie vielleicht.
Auch meine falsche Verbindung herstellen oder so. Ähm da gab's dann vielleicht auch mal Beschwerden. Ähm,
Aber grade jetzt zum Beispiel siehst du dann irgendwie Sandwohn, Lobby ist mit Bundestagshausausweisen hinzugefügt. Da hast du dann jetzt irgendwie auch sehen können, ne? Wer welchem Verein eben den Haus,
Hausausweis verschafft hat und solche Geschichten. Aber das ZDF auf jeden Fall sagt, wir unterstützen dieses Produkt nicht mehr äh finanziell,
und es wird jetzt halt Open Source sein mit einem eigenen Gitterprepo und da kann man eben einsehen und weiterentwickeln. Und die Leute von Open Detas City suchen jetzt nach neuen Partnern,
Um dieses Projekt weiterzuführen und auch auf die europäische Ebene zu bringen,
und ist ja schon sehr interessant ähm dass hier.
Dieses Gerücht wird sich natürlich erstmal nicht offiziell bestätigen lassen, ja, weil die kritischen Stimmen.
Im Rundfunkrat werden sich jetzt nicht an die Öffentlichkeit wagen und das ZDF hat die,
Einflussnahme des Rundfunkrates hier auch zurückgewiesen. Aber es ist schon sehr erstaunlich, dass ausgerechnet so ein Projekt dann beim ZDF unter die Räder kommt,
weil ähm die Wirkmacht dieses Projektes offenbar schon den Leuten ähm klar geworden ist.
Also dieses Plug-in wird's dann aber trotzdem noch geben.
Das gibt's noch und ja, müssen wir jetzt halt gucken, dass wir das weiter äh ähm betreiben.
Müssen wir auch mal installieren. Vielleicht noch gar nicht aufm Radar, den Lobby-Radar.
Aber man sieht hier natürlich die Lügenpresse, ne, wie die Lügenpresse mit der Politik.
Oh Gott, das hast du jetzt nicht.
Ah ja, wir hatten zur letzten Sendung so schöne äh so schön viele Kommentare. Da müssen wir ja hier auch nochmal ein noch mal ein paar uns einfangen.
Womit wir beim Ende wären.
Ja, nahezu fast. Also eigentlich schon.
Wieso was hast du noch? Nichts?
Ich stelle nur ähm fest, dass immer, wenn wir immer, wenn du reinkommst und sagst, das geht heute ganz schnell. Wir haben ja nur ein paar Sachen, dass wir dann schnell im Grundsatzdiskussionen,
ausufern, was ich aber gut finde eigentlich. Wie viele Sendungen haben wir eigentlich noch dieses Jahr?
Hm, können nicht mehr so viele sein.
Nee, ich gucke gerade mal. Ich glaube, nächste Woche sind wir schon noch mal äh verabredet, aber das war's dann auch.
Danach die Woche ist schon die letzte Woche vom Kongress und dann ist Kongress.
Oh mein Gott. Nee, da können wir nicht. Also übernächste Woche gehe ich gar nicht. Und danach die Woche vielleicht. Da Kongress müssen wir gucken, ob wir da Zeit finden. Aber haben wir, glaube ich, schon verraten, dass wir da Zeit finden müssen, ne?
Na wir fassen das ins Auge, sagen wir es mal so. Wir werden nochmal schauen, ähm diese ganzen,
Planungen für Kongress, für den Kongress. Also, ich glaube, gefühlt bei so ziemlich jedem Beginn das irgendwie mehr oder weniger jetzt. Jetzt, oh, Kongress, jetzt müssen wir uns was einfallen lassen und so. Fuck.
Ja.
Ciao. Ein Kongress, der ausverkauft ist.
Wer hätte damit rechnen können.
Tja, na ja, das hat sich abgezeichnet.
Hatte halt drei Jahre gedauert, wo immer irgendwie dreitausend Leute mehr kamen als vorher. Das machste halt nicht äh ewig bei begrenzter Kapazität, ne.
Ich meine, das ist krass, das ist einfach, es ist einfach unfassbar, aber es war auch es hat sich halt abgezeichnet, weil,
Ich überlege gerade, wie viele Teilnehmer wohl dieser Kongress jetzt haben würde,
wäre die Kapazität höher oder irgendwie unbegrenzt. Schwer zu beantworten, aber.
Die Nachfrage ist auf jeden Fall ungebrochen. Wer sich jetzt, wem jetzt gerade klar wird, dass er immer noch kein Ticket hat und äh gerne dort hinkommen wollen würde, na ja, wird schwierig.
Ist alles ganz gut ausverkauft und ähm da muss man halt mal schauen, ob irgendwelche Leute vielleicht ihre Tickets, die sie gekauft haben, nicht wahrnehmen und dann schnell zugreifen.
Am besten twittern.
Warum nicht.
Am besten den Hashtag zweiunddreißig C drei kaputt machen.
Ja, das scheint, also das machen so viele, da muss irgendwas, da muss funktionieren.
Ja. Nee. Ja, äh, was soll ich dazu sagen? Ich meine, der Vorverkauf war lange genug da und es ist verbergen sich dahinter viele hundert dramatische Einzelschicksale, denen.
Geholfen werden kann.
Denen nicht geholfen werden kann.
Und das ist äh bitter und die Erfahrung hatten wir auch im Sommer mit dem Camp.
Camp. Das hatten wir auch schon vorher in Berlin, mehrere Jahre gehabt leider.
In Berlin war's noch tragischer.
Viel tragischer. Wenn man jetzt mal berücksichtigt, dass wir hier mal so locker die vierfache Menge an Leuten bearbeiten können.
Also aber ja, ich meine, es ist.
Streaming.
Das ist richtig, gibt der hervorragende Streaming und.
Man kann äh live bei den Veranstaltungen auch im Chat dabei sein, Fragen stellen. Ich weiß, das ist nicht dasselbe, aber das ist immerhin schon mal was. Ja, aber grade nicht im Angebot.
Nehmt mehr als quasi mehr als einen Vorverkauf, längere Zeit offen lassen und alle äh kaufen lassen, die dran denken, kann man eben leider nicht machen, ja.
Machen. Ja, das ist das Blöde.
Klar könnten wir jetzt irgendwie ja, also.
Müssen unser eigenes Kongresszentrum bauen. Wird kein Weg.
Ja, weil die uns das nächstes Jahr abreißen, übernächstes Jahr.
Na ja Dauerkongress.
Na ja, okay. So ist das.
So ist das. Aber wir bleiben euch erhalten. Nächste Woche geht's weiter und ja, wenn ihr dann auf dem Kongress seid, dann sagt doch mal guten Tag, aber das können wir ja nächste Woche noch mal besprechen. Dann jetzt erstmal tschüss.
Und danken dem Michael. Bis dahin.
Genau, das tun wir. Tschüss.